l'histoire étreint la france en cet
hiver 76 le rapt plus le meurtre d'un
jeune garçon épouvante à temps l'auteur
fut cynique odieux
les mouches se sont alors emballée au
soir la france a peur un enfant est mort
un 12 enfants au regard profond
assassiné étranglé ou étouffé on ne sait
pas encore le top 6 ne l'a pas
complètement révélé par le monstre qui
l'avait enlevée pour de l'argent patrick
henry est une relation de la famille il
fut interviewé à plusieurs reprises
avant son arrestation il n'était alors
que le suspect numéro un et les parents
viennent de lancer un appel au ravisseur
est pire qu avait quand même beaucoup de
coïncidences reconnaissait le vous même
qui faisait quand même que vous auriez
pu enfin vous corresponde exactement
ouais bien sûr bien sûr il ya eu des
coïncidences qui ont qui ont fait que
d'ailleurs pose c'est pourquoi la police
s'est adressé à moi c'est des
coïncidences
puis il ajoute au micro d'une radio
je pense que c'est oui le corps du petit
garçon fut découvert sous le lit de la
chambre d'hôtel que patrick henry avait
loué l'assassin est indéfendable
il encourt la peine de mort que 400
manifestants viennent réclamer à
l'ouverture du procès dans une
plaidoirie flamboyante robert badinter
son avocat arash patrick henry à la
guillotine
il est condamné à perpétuité en janvier
robert badinter devenu garde des sceaux
combat alors la peine de mort
entre autres à partir de l'exemple de
patrick henry sachez bien que dans la
foule
tu as trois trier au passage de bus fait
de bons temps au tour du palais de
justice
amar pu faire à moins bon temps se
trouvait un jeune homme qui s'appelait
patrick henry croyez moi à ma
stupéfaction quand je les ai appris j'ai
compris ce que ce jour-là pouvait
signifier la valeur dissuasive que la
peine de mort après 24 ans de cellules
patrick henry attendent derrière les
murs de la prison de caen aux yeux du
ministère de la justice
il présente aujourd'hui toutes les
garanties possibles d'une réinsertion
prisonnier modèle il a consacré sa
détention aux études un travail l'attend
à sa sortie qui pourrait intervenir
avant l'été